bunny sits and McDonald's with a
defibrillated hard-on due to the fact
that underneath the keshia's red and
yellow uniform she has hardly any
clothes on hugely enjoyed writing this
novel you know it was it was enormous ly
liberating experience it's a much more
natural art form for me to a fault
I think my songs have that feeling
they're kind of bursting at the seams
with kind of lyrical information it's
about an in sexually incontinent hand
cream salesman that works the south
coast of England trying to sleep with as
many women as he can and look after his
nine-year-old boy and of course he has
this nine-year-old son sitting opposite
him flip-flopping his feet smiling his
wonky smile and playing with a plastic
Darth Vader figurine that came free with
his happy meal now what was important
for me there was to write a character
that was ultimately a monster but at the
same time the reader could see an aspect
of themselves within within that
character especially the male reader
female readers are loving this book
because it's at last their suspicions of
the male psyche her and Ben confirmed
the cashier wears a name tag that says
Emily and she keeps glancing over at
bunny with huge vacant eyes and wiggling
all around she has a black lacquered
beehive and a conga line of raw acne
across her forehead and a vagina the
book itself is like a dream a kind of
hallucination of some sort and plays
around not with time in the sense that
it goes back and forward but the
movement is often slowing down in scenes
and speeding up and is that there's a
definite sort of musical rhythm that
goes on with the language that comes
from being a musician I guess Merlin was
the son of an incubus and a mortal woman
and the boy looks up Incubus and finds
that an incubus is a malevolent spirit
who has intercourse with women in their
sleep then looks up intercourse and
thinks Wow
imagine that I read the first chapter on
the iPhone and then the kind of novelty
of that wore off and I you know I got
out of pen and opened a notebook and
wrote the rest of it by hand it's it's a
novel it's an audio book and it's an app
the audio book is something that I spent
a lot of time over I'm hugely proud of
that I'm a big fan personally of
audiobooks I tried to do something that
was a wholly new way of doing an audio
book I read it first of all and then me
and Warren Ellis scored the whole thing
it was it was not unlike scoring a a
film the way that me and Warren Ellis go
about scoring movies is we basically
work with directors that prefer to be
sent lumps of music and that they cut
the lumps of music into the film rather
than sitting and spotting spotting by
writing a 15-second piece of tension
musical as a stuff and then we send it
to the states where it was spatialized
so if you if you listen to it with
headphones on it's like a hallucination
or something Bonnie put this to Poodle
down the week 1 lunchtime and poodles
self-proclaimed sexpert and barracuda
argue that eating a tuna carpaccio was
actually a lot more like eating
than a Big Mac a certain sound effects
that actually feel like they're
physically touching you and I mean it's
it's it's an it's an extraordinary kind
of psychedelic experience
I know I've gone back to vinyl you know
after a long time but I mean sonically
it's just so much warmer and a more
intimate and it's a you know it's a
different experience to pick up that you
know put a record on a turntable one
there's something very intimate about
that and a lot less disposable feeling